Well mr.
Edwards. I understand you worked on the
sydney harbour bridge in the workshops for
a time as right. Have you know do
you want the time that was in 1920
eight. I was there for
about ten months and then
i got married i was called back on the
railways and went up to cardiff you worked
in the in the workshops i understand. Yes
i work mainly in what we call the heavy
shop that was the shop
that the have to the
preliminary work had been done on the
members and it came up and then we assemble
the innards of the large members and revision
gradually shifted up then to the far
end of the shop where it went in into
a dock and every joint it was my
there before it was taken out then
and floated out from the workshop and taken
out to the bridge and then that piece
would be moved up and another one brought
up. They would make that your point. So
that when they were lifted up onto the
site there was no risk of holes not coming
in the right position and everything
just feeling like you could be like
a jigsaw puzzle. How was the work aligned
and set up in the workshop ready for your
to make the joint. Oh well
when parts were being put
on
a machine for planning or anything
like that me and doormen long's staff
they would set it up with theodolite. So
that everything was just plumb and before
it was worked on then the public works
department. Survivors they would come along
with their theodolite you know everything
was checked and double checked to make
sure that it was perfect in all its parts.
So that it would be able to be assembled
exactly how did they check it. Oh well as
i just mentioned lead level that up on
the on the machines and so
they do they use feelers or
and how much to check rivets or my wording
when they were checking rivets years ago
see them going along they might
they might take some time at about
a couple of minutes to determine whether
certain dravot would be loose. If it had
the slightest movement. It'd be marked
and had to be taken out and say they
give the rivet a good hides back
one way and put their finger on
a tap at the other way and if they could
feel the slightest movement out of red
come and then it couldn't be kept of the
head of it couldn't be cut off with oxy it
had to be cut off with
a pneumatic machine. The bottom i could
have to come along and kept there down
there with
a machine you made it machine. And so the
dvd be no damage done to the to the plate
and even before rivers were put
in they would come along with
a little square that would fit down into
the holes and make sure that the holes
were drilled at right angles
to the surface of the material
and when
a joint was made. What with the tolerances
allowed on it but for instance what were
the tolerances was the toilets on the
button i think. Well there was no tolerance
on machined work but and they are
normally hot rivets you are you a drill
a hole about a sixteen bigger
like for a thirteen for
a three quarter to rivet you drilled
a thirteen sixteen hour or
seven eight riveted drill
a fifteen sixteen hole and so on you. It
allowed sixteen to expansion of the hot
river but with the all work
in the bridge was only
a thirty second of an inch. Clearance
allowed for rivets so that you and
you had
a quarter rivet you would just allow another
thirty seconds of an edge for it in to
go in and they always had to be hammered
in because of the expansion of the hot
rivet do you remember in addition to the
the accuracy that was required. You
remember the size of things. Do you ever
come across anything that size anywhere
else. Just repeat that i didn't
do you ever come across any size
of work because the what was
required on the harbour bridge
. Well what used to him
fresh me was the size of
the members. We had to to go ahead
travelling crying as that would that have
a capacity of one hundred twenty ten each
and they would pick those members up that
you see on the bridge now. And they look
tremendously bigger than what they look
when they're out there on the site
where you would see these two
cranes one of each end of i mean lifted
up and carried that from one end of the
shock to the other it was
a tremendous amount of steel that you
see lifted and and take it up in one
piece. When you do you ever go out
on the bridge at all. Now the
first time i went on the bridge was the day
everyday and and i walked across it. I
was never out on the site. You know all the
fabrication was done in the shop where
luna park is now that was where our workshop
i was. Although there's probably still
quite
a lot of people that have the idea that
the bridge was fabricated in england and
brought out here and just put together
that that is quite erroneous every part of
that bridge was fabricated in their workshop
they we're going to where luna park is
now can you tell me exactly the process
of the work of the job you did in the
workshops as it went along. All i
was a mainly assembling i did do
a little bit of marking off but they're
mainly assembling and what we yeah and did
eventually just after the arts were
starting to take shape. So as to keep the
work going in the daytime. We started an
evening shift we used to work from up ask
for an afternoon at 11:30 where he
would assemble members of the bridge
about them together put pins in
and when i say pins there might
figure that then what you normally call
a pin those two pins the size of the holes
you drive those in not drips they are
parallel pins. So support them
in position then the take ship
people they would come along and carry on
the idea of that was to get all the crane
work done. Because it was
a tremendous amount of work that had to be
lifted devout and it used to waste time
if youre waiting for
a crane so thats what we used to do then.
Do you mean what the working conditions
were like in the shop. Oh their working
conditions were quite good at that there
at that time i suppose working conditions
today very much jeff and its quite
a few years since i left the trade
but. They were they were good working
conditions for that time. Do you ever how
you went to work and how you went home
and i used to get the
tram from. From roads by
driving at that. Why get the train from
road going to king street and then walk
down to circular can get the best across
a kit the ferry across out of melting point
and say might just reverse it coming
back there were still plenty of ferries and
buses around eleven o'clock at night. I
was still i got the tram because
in those days they used to call
a tram after midnight there all night
trams and you try to extra fare and but
then that that was counteracted different
morning you get work went for years
you'd go from. From one guy into circular
quay for tuppence and the early morning
on a workman's train
workman's tram which was
a do you remember seeing any of the. The
top people of doormen long around the site
. I as they were. They were
frequently erring on the avon doctor
bradford. He used to come there quite
a lot and it's even on the second shift.
Sometimes you get in there on the second
shift and he would go and talk to anybody
in the shop i didn't matter who he was
there was nobody to inferior for dr.
Bradfield to talk to you and then do you
remember having a conversation with
a mata
a few times i would be going over on the
ferry when i was going over and kept quite
a few times i spoke to him and i remember
once talking to him and. He was talking
about the stresses and strains and that
and how that during the construction.
It was calculated that the work was stand
a wind velocity of up to one hundred twenty
miles an hour not kilometres in those
age but it would stand to
have an average of five
a loss. I think of one hundred twenty
miles an hour ago that was during
construction and of course
a lot of present construction and
there was strengthening pieces bolted
under the inside of the members.
Because at that in the construction
stage the work was on
a tensile strength and tension i
was trying but then when it was
joined together of course it became
a compacted strain and then though those
pieces were taken out and finally
riveted up. Do you remember who was it was
in charge of the other shift in the in
the workshop. The foreman.
That was there when when when
i was there was a chap named
arthur down. I mean i fell
a tale. Can you tell me if. The doorman
longstaff went to different to the
australian people in the ways of work
or in their sort of attitude to working
people. Now we got we got on quite
well i think there would be
a i think bigger proportion
of local men and then
he just brought out for the particular work
on the bridge. What sort of the people
that did come out from elsewhere
where did they come from some came
from ireland scotland and i thought i'd say
the majority of those that did come out
would have been from england and they made
their own way. Norman longer than bring
them. I didn't know of it on the wrong
helping anybody and i think they came with
their own volition. Do you remember any
amusing incidents in the workshop or will
it be sort of its density
and music incidents and
a tragic incident things that stick
in your mind and i know. It is.
It's more or less like in the other. Steel
construction place. There's nothing
that i could recall an amusing wending but
probably there would have been out on
the site
a lot more events would have happened out
there and more casualties there wasn't
much in the way of serious accidents
that i can recall in the workshop.
Do you remember what you did after you got
laid off that. Well i didn't get laid
off. I got
a call from the writer i used to go back
there and that was just at the start of
the depression years and i was went up then
and worked in the right way. Workshops
at cardiff. If you work there. All through
the depression. I was there right
through the depression i was at carter
from nineteen twenty nine and 1933 right
through the main four years of the depression
because it wasn't quite over then.
But it was easing off. Do you remember
where you were when you got taken on the
bridge or did you work at it. We are working
on another job immediately before we
are to work now. I was working then on the
air and installation of the boilers that
banner on power showed working for
babcock and wilcox then and i got
a call from don along ceo you know to the
bridge. So i wasn't out of work at all.
So you know we were you one of the lucky
ones. Or was it easier for the people who
were already been tradesmen before.
Well i actually i expect i was
a paid one of the lucky ones. I i never
had any period of unemployment at all
although when we're in the depression
years in the in the right way we run
rationing when you start it off or your
erection off one weekend for that is where
you work three weeks you have one off then
it gradually got expanded out and one in
seven and then it got out about
one in thirteen without pay.
Oh yes. You didn't get paid for the way
for the week or so now. And their wages.
They've gone down
a bit to you might try to
party was and. Resisting the
$5 a week if i found
a week and as i said do you remember how
much you got paid in the workshops. I can
tell you exactly how i was
on this is so if it's
a six panel eleven and she
span eleven and temperance
week getting in on that shift and
what do you is that that was and that
twenty eight twenty nine. And then we do
you when you went on the railways you pay
went down to that i mean
down the years. It went down
a little bit because they used to take in
account that we get paid for holidays of
course in those days the private jobs.
You didn't they didn't even get paid for
public holidays and there was no
paid holidays at all in private
employment in those days we see it one way
holiday. On full pay in the railways and
paid for public holidays and of course
that was taken into account. So
a weekly way would rise was
a little bit lower than the outside people
do you remember any union activity while
you worked on the bridge. And now everything
went along very sprightly i was just
an ordinary member of the
union at my door and i i
took more an active part when i came back
to sydney i was working at the chiller
electric car shops and i was the
union rep there for thirteen years
and i was i mean to the bottom make
is red phone banks with a bottom like
a union will. Is there anything
standing at all that you can think of
that happen to you or your member on the
bridge. Now is just. Everything we need to
have quite smoothly and we never had any
trouble at all. Fact i enjoyed the work
there and it was quite
a trish up whether i left that and went
back onto the railway or i just i just got
married i was only married three weeks but
i got that called back to the right way
. Vishesh
a trish up like their job there and how we
thought well that's going to fizzle out
and better to go on the railways where
their job will carry on. Now. Looking back
on those times you know the bridge
is now fifty years old. Why
do you think of the old coat
hanger now. Well i think it's
a great credit to the work of boilermakers
you know they were trying with the
engineers a society. There and
that's good enough provided i'm
a good bet that work had to be spot on
your member of the it was how it came
together like clockwork when the
job was finished i think that was
a credit to boilermakers what do you think
about the suggestion that they put extra
lines on the bridge now i think it's
a calamity that bridge was never
designed for that. Where where the trams
used to run that was originally meant
to be the future railway line for the
rail out to palm beach the vale was
extremely intended to be standing
up there. And i think it would be
a calamity to alter the
appearance. It would be to be
a desecration i say would be defacing the
the design of the bridge and they are
they talk about the heritage council.
Maintaining things as they are and i
think that they should come under
their control and not allow any. Defacing
of the structure of that bridge at all.
Well thank you very much mr. Edwards.